hello I'm Hannah K and welcome to this
intelligence Squad event with Yasha monk
there are various ways in which you can
get involved you can ask questions join
in the audience chat and tweet us using
the hashtag iq2 and on the right hand
side of your screen you'll see a link
where you can get a copy of yash's new
book the identity trap a story of ideas
and Power in our time and it's a
brilliant account of giving the
intellectual roots of current ideas
about sex race and gender and a valiant
plea for liberal and Universal values
but now I'm delighted to hand over to
our chair he is the author and critic
Tommy oadi over to you Tom thank you
Hannah um tonight's event is going to
run for about one hour for the first 45
minutes or so I'm going to be in
conversation with Yasha and then after
that I'm going to be taking your
questions you can start asking them now
by clicking clicking on the ask question
button under the video screen and typing
in your question if you want your name
to be mentioned type it into the box
then press send you could also take part
in a conversation um or you on Twitter
all you need to do is to tweet us using
the hashtag
iq2 now Yasha um the very first question
I want to ask you is that with the um
current war in Ukraine um with Israel's
conflicts with Gaza with um the climate
crisis do you think writing about
identity issues um is a distraction from
what some people might consider the more
Salient issues affecting us in the world
today uh well thanks thanks for that
question um and and I don't think it is
I like to say that I'm a democracy
crisis hipster I've been worried about
the crisis of democracy since before it
was cool and made my name in books like
the people versus democracy warning
about the rise of populism especially if
not exclusively on the right um and and
what it would do to our Democratic
systems um and I remain very concerned
about that I'm coming to you virtually
I'm sad not to be able to be in person
with everybody uh from New York City uh
and you know Donald Trump is running
neck to neck with Joe Biden in polls for
the 2024 elections and I'm worried about
that too so why write a book about uh
what I see as uh the the threat uh from
a misguided set of ideas uh about race
gender and sexual orientation that is
grown up on the left on the part of
political Spectrum uh to which I myself
belong over the course of the last
decade um well I I think these ideas are
trap which is to say that there's a lure
there's something that uh is appealing
to people that promises to make the
world better uh the identity the the
ideology claims that it is what allows
people in the most principled uh
radical compromising possible
way uh to G the injustices that
undoubtedly persist in our societies but
I think it is a trap as we've started to
see in the last years it's a trap that
makes it much harder for Progressive
institutions to actually serve important
missions it is a trap that in key uh
public policy decisions leads us astray
makes it harder for us uh to actually um
uh cre find Solutions uh that will gain
broad support and that will make world a
better place I think it actually
encourages in our politics and in our
culture a zero some conflict um between
different uh ethnic and other identity
groups which is going to make it much
harder to sustain our political systems
and as a result um it's a shua to think
think that you need to prioritize
between fighting um right-wing populism
and fighting this ideology um Donald
Trump's victory in 2016 was one of the
reasons why it became very hard to
criticize these ideas on the left
especially in the United States because
it was easy to accuse you of being a
traitor who was running interference for
Trump but it's the hold of these ideas
over so many mainstream institutions and
over so much of a left and over parts of
the democratic party which helps to
explain why Trump uh is continuing to do
very well in polls for 2024 and I'd like
to note here the contrast what other
people might like or dislike about K
dama with the United Kingdom where labor
leader who has drawn a very clear line
of division between himself and the left
is running 20 points ahead in the poll I
think that that is a related phenomenon
and finally I'd just like to say that
the last weeks should have made it very
obvious how badly wrong these ideas can
go the conflict in the Middle East is
very complicated
um it does have a long history I can
understand um that people's sympathies
May lie more of one side or or or the
other hopefully rely to some extent with
with civilian victims on both sides um
but the unwillingness and the inability
of big parts of the left in the last
weeks to acknowledge the sheer scale and
brutality of a terrorist attack but
Hamas
perpetrated killing over
1,400 civilians the fact that um big
parts of the uh left movement in the
United States including the Democratic
Socialist for America and chapters of
black lives matter actively celebrated
this Slaughter um uh uh idolized uh uh
the paragliders who killed over 250
people at that music festival that I
think is absolutely part and parcel of a
topic of my book because it is um when
you start to see the world through
simplistic identity categories thinking
that you can understand a conflict like
the Middle East as simply pitting whites
versus people of color colonizers versus
the colonized uh um and so on uh that
you end up with that kind of deep uh
moral uh uh lack of clarity thank you um
in what ways has your own personal
background as a German Jewish person
shape the writing of this
book um well I mean I think part of my
book is to argue that we should be
reluctant to um Define ourselves too
much by our own identities which does
not of course mean that we need to deny
them or that I'm unaware of the fact
that that's shaped me in certain ways as
I'm sure it has shaped you in certain
ways but I really worry when uh many of
our social practices today encourage a
kind of personal ident trap I've talked
about the political elements of this
trap very briefly and perhaps we can
delve into it more in the conversation
but at the personal level I think if
you're teaching students as many schools
now do that the way to really find
recognition and belonging in the world
is to conceive you of yourselves
primarily by the specific intersection
of identities in which you belong um
that sets you up for failure and that
important Endeavor most of us do want
some form of social belonging some form
of social recogntion um but I will never
fully feel that recognition if I'm
treated in an identical way to my
brother even though my brother has a
very similar identity to me um and so I
so so so I think part of that is is a
personal recognition that that is not
what I want to be seen for in the world
and what I want to be defined as in the
world certainly not from the outside um
you know there some other things here
right one of them is that um uh you know
growing up in Germany I experienced some
outright
anti-Semitism um I also
experienced a good amount of somewhat
creepy philosemitism you know Germans
who wanted to prove to me that were so
sorry for the past and so ashamed of the
third R um that uh you know they love
the Jews um and you know this took all
kinds of absurd forms at the time this
would be more controversial now um it
was you know people telling me how much
Bel love the alen movies or ask I speak
Hebrew and how beautiful the Hebrew
language is I don't speak a word of
Hebrew right um and and I always
realized that that didn't help me at all
to feel like an equal made me feel
patronized and like it was actually
harder for me to to develop a truly
German identity and now one of the
strange thing that's happened when I
moved to the United States is that I
went from being a
representative of sort of the the
seminal group of victims in the country
I say um to a representative of a
seminal uh group of perpetrators which
say white men um this Point white
middle-aged man um and and I in certain
social situations I I came to feel an
expectation but I should act in ways or
treat people in ways but I hated being
treated as in in Germany and so perhaps
if there is a link it is my recognition
that some of those social Customs that
are now being embraced are deeply
antical to equality one of the you know
in the book I talk about the more
serious ious uh progenitors of what I'm
call theen synthesis but I also talk
about some of their
popularizers people like Robin DeAngelo
who is one of the bestselling authors in
the United States and in the United
Kingdom in in in 2020 and D'Angelo a
white woman who makes lot of money as a
diversity trainer says that every time a
white person interrupts a black person
by bringing the entire apparatus of
white supremacy to bear on them right
that first of all takes tells me that
she doesn't have black friends because
part of what it is to have friends is
that you sometimes interrupt each other
but secondly it's precisely this sort of
you know in a social situation in a
strange way uh you know trying to prove
to each other how aware you are of the
identity and sort of being over that's
exactly what I hated experiencing in
Germany and I and I think that has
informed my worries about people like de
being a good guide for how we create
real social equality in in Britain or
United States or elsewhere
today yeah fantastic um why do you use
the term identity syn synthesis in your
book rather than identity politics or
work politics or even cultural Marxism
as like some people
do yeah um so one of the strange things
about this ideology is that we really
don't have a term that's uncontroversial
that we can use serious as a basis for
serious debate right um some people in
Britain consider themselves socialists
some people don't like the idea of
socialism at all but all of them can
agree to refer to you know a broad um uh
body of ideas that has some internal
tensions but that is you know
recognizably a an an ideology that hangs
together a socialist right um I think we
now have a new ideology that has become
dominant on the left an ideology that
puts
ideas about the role that identity plays
in the world and the role that identity
should play in the world at the very
basis of our political thinking but we
don't have a coherent term for it um you
know woke is the most recognizable term
it used to be a self-description right
um activists proudly called themselves
woke um five or six years ago um but now
it's become such a term of appr probium
that when he talking about work this and
work that he sort of just s sound like
an old man shouting at the clouds and um
I think it makes it harder to have a
serious debate um identi politics I
think is a little bit too broad um you
know Frederick Douglas in the United
States and and Martin Luther King or uh
some of the key uh uh some of the key
members of the Civil Rights Movement um
uh or the gay rights movement have also
engaged in what might be called forms of
identity politics but because what they
were ask asking for was inclusion in a
set of universal institutions was to
live up to the promise of these
long-standing uh rules um I actually am
inspired by them and agree with them on
many things my my concern is about an
identity an ideology that explicitly
stands in opposition to these ideas says
as Derek Bell the found of critical race
Fury said that we should reject the
quote defunct Racial equality IDE ology
of a civil rights movement so identity
politics for me is too broad and
cultural Marxism the third possibility
you you mentioned um simply is uh
misdescribed the nature of a phenomenon
um so the idea here is that you take
something like the Marxist tradition you
take out economic categories like social
class and you put in these identity
categories like race and gender and
sexual orientation now the first problem
with this is that I just don't think
there's enough left um in America I say
a little bit like taking the bat out of
baseball I guess here I'd have to say
it's taking the bat out of cricket or
the ball out of football you know um
doesn't work quite as well but there is
just not enough meat left on the
ideology once you take economic
categories out and as a matter of
intellectual history it turns out to be
wrong to think that these ideas
originate in you know Marx and you know
Adon and Haim and and other people like
that um that is just not when I started
to read the intellectual history what
turned out to be the true story so I
call the identity synthesis simply
because it is a synthesis of different
intellectual influences which I locate
in modernism and postcolonialism and
critical race Theory and it is centrally
about the role that identity plays in
our society but as Freddy de V Mar over
has said I don't care what you call it
you know just tell me what I'm allowed
to call it so we can have a Ser
discussion about it if you want to call
it the thing let's call
it fantastic um to what extent do you
think this um new identity synthesis as
you put it um and the conflict between
this and the kind of liberalism that you
espouse to what extent do you think that
conflict is an intergenerational
conflict um so you know it may have
elements of a generational conflict um
certainly we often see that new ideas
are you know spread as Thomas
pointed out in the structure of scien
utions through a kind of process of
generational change um but I think it
would be very big mistake to assume that
older people aren't tempted by these
ideas or that young people invariably
end up embracing them I think one of the
big reasons why these ideas have been
able to gain so much influence so
quickly is that many older uh people who
are in charge of Institutions um did not
have a courage of their convictions and
actually became semic converts to this
new ideology or at least for this new
ideology as sufficiently aligned with
their own that they were not able to
recognize how it undermined some of the
other core commitments and and and would
would would land Us in this trap we're
we're talking about today and among
younger Generations um you know it is a
minority uh and not NE ethnic or
religious minority but an ideological
minority
that that really Embraces these ideas
there may also be and it's too early to
save us with with with confidence and so
I've never written about this um there
may also starting starting to be push
back among the youngest people when I
look you know at at at at students I had
four or five years ago very were excited
by these ideas they were True Believers
um uh you know they really thought this
is what's going to allow them to remake
the world when I look at the students I
have now at University they're deeply
steeped in these ideas years they've
been told from from from one where six
years old that this is how they should
see the world often they've been raised
in accordance with a social practices
inspired by these ideologist many of my
students now have been part of mandatory
uh racially segregated Affinity groups
where often teachers came into their
classroom as early as you know when
we're eight or seven or six and said if
you're black you go over there and if
you're Asian americ you go over there
and if you're Latino you go over there
and if you're white you go to the fourth
classroom so they're kind of growing up
with its atmosphere but in part as a
result they see its flaws they've seen
classmates of theirs canceled over
supposed microaggressions um when they
were 12 or 13 um they've had countless
uh lectures and trainings um uh about uh
uh you know all of these ideas and
Concepts and many of them uh uh
therefore don't find it exciting think
of it as what the adult are telling them
and so on so I think the generational
question is hard what's much clearer is
the
uh question of social class which is to
say the best studies we have in in the
United States in Britain and other
places show that the people who really
buy into these ideas uh the people who
mour common um in one study has called
sort Progressive activists who roughly
correspond to R viws I'm talking about
are disproportionately white
disproportionately affluent and
disproportionately highly
educated fantastic
um what would you say to those that
argue that the desire for the identity
synthesis is shaped by the fact that um
many people want a sense of belonging um
a sense of belonging which would have in
the past been expressed through
affiliation to religion affiliation to
being a member of a political party
affiliation to being a member
of a local Civic institution and of the
decline of institutional religion the
decline of party political membership
the decline of Civic local institutions
where should people go to seek a sense
of
belonging yeah I think that's right you
know when I was at University I probably
assumed that the process of
secularization which was continuing to
advance in already very secular
societies like written well was it
University and you know the continent
where it grew up but also in the United
States was sort of behind the curve but
increasingly looks like it's simply you
know 30 years later um but the
development looks quite similar actually
um though was going to be a good thing
right that religion had often inspired
hatred conflict Mutual dehumanization as
we're seeing in the world right now
again um and that uh uh societies
becoming less and less religious would
make them more and more tolerant would
allow us to see what we have in common
more I think we're seeing in the United
States in particular uh that this has
turned out to be a very mixed blessing
but a lot of the people who no longer go
to church every Sunday um find their
belonging um in extreme online
communities or simply become so lonely
so withdrawn from any genuine social
ties but they're much more vulnerable to
extremist appeals um uh that helps to
explain the rise of people like Donald
Trump but I think it also helps to
explain
some of what we're seeing on the left um
I I disagree with the very insightful
and and smart um uh American commentator
John mcarter who thinks that uh uh what
he calls workism is literally a religion
but it literally should be F of as a
religion I don't think that's true I
think um it has the characteristics of a
political ideology that are shared by
many different political ideologies and
things like Marxism were not a religion
even though
some of their adherence might have had a
sort of form of religious fervor but
what's certainly true is that it's
speaking to a
deeply uh religious and in some ways
specifically
Puritan um moral imaginary um you know
when Europeans look at America they
sometimes
imagine that puritanism continues to
have a hold because of um you know
because Society is relatively more Rel
but I think that the shape of puran
ideology has as much hold in communities
around Harvard University where I've
lived for a long time for example than
it does in the South with the Midwest um
the substance of the beliefs they hold
are very different they don't believe in
the kind of um constraints and morality
and so on the ancestors believed it even
probably actually mostly very
conventional k b lives um but certainly
so once they are out of their mid-20s
and you know settle down and get married
and have children and so on much more so
than in Europe um but uh when it comes
to the need to live in a morally pure
and clean community and the ways in
which people who are suspected of
befouling that Purity are cast out um I
think that the people whose uh
propositional views at a superficial
level have least similar it to the
Puritan ancestors actually are the
inheritors of a Puritan moral
imagination uh to a remarkable
extent great um what is Tumblr and what
is the significance of Tumblr in shaping
the identity
synthesis yeah so so in the book I uh it
has four parts right in the first part
really tells the intellectual history of
where these ideas come from um
explaining how thinkers like Michelle
Fuko and Edward S and gatri spok and um
Derek Bell and Kimberly crenell together
developed the set of ideas that made uh
that provided the ground material uh for
what has become the identity synthesis
what has become if you prefer the term
wokness um that's a very interesting and
funny story um it's slightly surprising
story I think many of the people who
developed those ideas um came to regret
it would not like the ideology in its
modern shape um but that's how
intellectual history often often Works
um and then the second part of the book
um I go on to ask well how is it that in
about 2010 those ideas had started to be
very influential uh on University
campuses on uh parts of the academy but
they really continue to be marginal to
society as a whole uh Kimberly crenchaw
in a paper uh sort of reflecting on the
20th anniversary of critical race Theory
uh said you
know we've it's great we've had good
careers we've established our position
in universities um and that's all nice
and well but we are not going to have
much influence on society in fact this
guy Barack Obama just got elected and
his basic political philosophy is
fundamentally at odds with the key
tenants of critical race Theory
something that people who think that
critical race theory is simply sort of
nice liberalism should remember um and
therefore our uh Prospect for influence
in the world has gotten even more remote
well over next 10 years I think her
influence ended up surprising crena and
many of the other theorists that were
part of this movement it started to
really be popularized be
repackaged uh in a way that could go
viral and could um not just become very
popular among a subsection of young
people um but could uh ex exert
tremendous influence on
politics and our mainstream institutions
and Tumblr I think is a key part of that
story um it is one of the first social
media uh platforms a micro blogging
platform as it was known of the time um
it had a lot of uh Teenage uh users as
well as some in the early 20s it allowed
a great variety of forms of content from
text to photos to memes to short videos
um and allowed Cru usually a form of
self-tagging self-discovery where you
could put on some kind of label which
often became an identity label and then
search for others that shared bad and uh
the way this worked out is that it
greatly expanded how people could
identify themselves when you think about
identity formation in an analog world
you really need to find a bunch of
people who agree with you on your
identity for it to be meaningful and if
you're going to a school then that meant
that you needed to find 10 people in
your local school that shared kind of
identity and so that limited the
possible range of identities to ones
that had you know about 1% of the
population otherwise you just wouldn't
find enough people to co-create at that
crucial moment well Tumblr because of
this tagging mechanism which was new at
the time just blew that constraint out
of the water and it became the place
where many of the identity labels that
have had a broader career sins um came
to be uh uh experimented with including
many of the gender label
um but also new forms of sexual
orentation like demisexual all of that
originated on Tumbler and then when you
started having these tribes where
everybody defined themselves by these
new identity labels and you had to
interact somehow you needed an ideology
that holds those interactions together a
kind of meta ideology and that came to
be where you started to think about
microaggressions and the dangers they
pose about the fact but when you offend
somebody it matters that that was the
outcome not what your intent was
um and it also started to take on some
of the sort of viral Expressions um that
helped proze this ideology and through a
few transformations in the written form
in places like Ford catalog and everyday
feminism. comom uh and then some
technological changes which um um
favored uh content which could spread on
social media platforms like Twitter and
Facebook along identity lines um these
ideas surprisingly quickly entered a
broader mainstream
audience just a remind that that you can
ask a question by clicking on the ask
question button under the video and then
press and send you could also take part
on social media by using the hashtag
iq2 um
Yasha to what extent are the mainstream
media also responsible for the identity
synthesis in the book you mention the
increase of terms like white privilege
and structural racism in the New York
Times and in the Washington Post over
the past 10
years uh yeah I think this is this is an
important part of the story and no way
was just where we're letting off right
um so it's remarkable how quickly these
ideas came to be influential in uh
mainstream news organizations and
there's two Pathways for this the first
is part of a wider instance of what I'm
calling the short March Prov
institutions which is to say by about
2010 um so many people were uh being
schooled in these ideas in Elite
universities in particular uh that they
started to transform the workplaces into
which they found out and the second is
that uh social media algorithms really
uh favored certain kinds of firstperson
stories rooted in genuine experiences
and sometimes less uh persuasive claims
of victimhood um you know when uh the
website rox.com which became influential
very quickly was founded a majority of
the traffic to this website came from
people uh who went to the homepage right
who typed in box.com into the web
browser and said is there anything there
that I want to read that
favored um content which would appeal to
you know most of of uh a publication's
readers um so a publication might have a
kind of profile more left leaning more
right leaning um but each article had to
appeal to a broad cross-section of its
usual readers um B 2015
2016 the distribution mechanism had
changed in such a way that most of the
traffic came from Facebook or Twitter
and people on Facebook or Twitter often
connected to others who share an
identity category and so suddenly these
first person story is about you know the
experiences I had growing up as a jumu
or growing up as an Asian-American or
you know as a disabled whatever whatever
right those could spread along those
social media networks in in in in new
way that's where the Cs were and so
suddenly if you went back to that
website in 2017 2018 the form of it had
changed from a sort of more analytical
frame to a much more first personal
frame and the politics had changed along
with it it had become a lot about these
experiences of of discrimination and
really putting them at the center of a
of a worldview and at the time the New
York Times And The Washington Post were
deep financial crisis which at least the
times is no longer but this is the
moment when the print Revenue was
cratering when the ad revenue from print
was cratering they had not yet buildt up
this massive base of online subscribers
that now sustains them and so they were
desperate for clicks and so they hired a
lot of writers they were more adapted
Mis adapted this game and so I do think
that uh these Publications ended up uh
uh sharing a bunch of respons ibility
for bad ideas being mainstreamed in two
ways first they published stuff that I
think um was just quite extreme right I
mean one one one opet in particular but
I'm thinking of in New York Times uh was
uh uh you know by by an African-American
writer saying I'm teaching my kids not
to be friends of white people because
you can never trust white people and I
don't want them to be friends with white
people effectively I it's a little bit
more subtle than that but was the core
of a message I just think that's a
irresponsible thing for something like
when New York Times uh to publish um
they're free to do so um I just think
that that is not where a majority of
audience was um it is not what most
Americans or most people in Britain
believe uh it just gives an indication
of how wide they open the doors to
content that would have for good reason
I think been considered quite Niche or
Fringe uh in previous uh uh iterations
and then the other thing that happened
is that there were certain champions of
these ideas but effectively came to be
Beyond criticism um people like Robin
D'Angelo and particularly ibr X Kandi
who uh argued for very manikan view of
what we call anti-racism uh according to
Candi
um uh you know everything is either
racist or antiracist so our conversation
is either racist or anti-racist but um
you know this this pair of scissors I'm
holding is either racist or anti-racist
um you know football is either racist or
anti-racist right there there's no
middle category it's surprisingly
similar to George W Bush's claim uh
after 911 that you're either with us or
against it us but it was widely embraced
and celebrated and I know from many
journalists at newspapers and magazines
in the United States who wanted to write
robust critiques of uh candi's ideas and
of the big Center for anti-racism that
he started at Boston University with
tens of millions of dollars in funding
and who were told in no on certain terms
that this was uh not publishable um that
it would be too controversial um to to
criticize verse verse ideas um that
started to change a little bit um Kandi
fired most of his staff um and does not
seem to have delivered on any of the
promises he made as funders and that was
a scandal big enough that suddenly the
FL Gates have opened and um now you're
seeing more Critical examination both of
that actual institution and of his
broader ideas but for a good number of
years years um you know mainstream
Publications just didn't want to go
there and and that I think is really
worrying it's worrying about the state
of our public sphere and public opinion
and it helps to explain the decline of
trust in these institutions you know I
have over the course of the last years
had so many conversations in Britain in
the United States in Continental Europe
with influential people who say
something like the sort of things we've
been saying this conversation today and
then add of course I would never say
this publicly and people aren't idiots
feel that they know that the people in
charge of Institutions say one thing to
each other and another thing to the
public and so why should they trust them
or why should they trust us because you
know you and I at this point are part of
those
institutions yeah well what do you make
of the idea um which is um expressed by
the political scientist um Adolf Reed um
and Reed argues that many of these
social movements dedicated to gender
race sexual orientation are simply an
extension of
neoliberalism they are um a way for many
corporations to justify pre-existing
inequalities so a corporation can say
well um 50% of the people on our board
are women 10% are black people without
saying anything about economic
inequality what do you make of that
argument so you know uh since we're
talking about identity one of my
identities is as a political scientist
and as a political scientist I love a
good two by two um you know simple
Matrix where you have four quadrants um
and uh I genuinely think this is a two
by two situation which is to say that um
if you have on one axis people on the
far left and people who are on the
center left and you have on the other
axis people who are woke and people who
are not woke I generally think that
there's people in all four of those
quadrants so there are people who are
um non-woke Center lefties which is
broadly what what I would consider
myself then I think there WS C lefties
who um you know love the diversity
initiatives at their uh uh corporations
who are super fans of D'Angelo and Candi
but who also you know want to become CFO
of their Fortune 500 company um but then
I think there's also you know a divide
on the farle um and there certainly are
people on the Revolutionary left who are
woke uh who Embrace these ideas in a
serious way and there people like out of
Reed um who's uh you know self-described
Marxist who probably would would happily
call himself as being on the far left
certainly economically um but who who
are really critical of of of these ideas
so I think it's a little bit more
complicated than he points out in that
kind of way I think it's true that there
is um I think sort of there is a deep
tension within people who embrace the
identity synthesis between those who who
think that you need to overthrow uh our
political and our economic system in
order to be true to its ideas and that's
certainly what the founders of these
ideas uh you know including people like
Derek Bell would have believed um but
then I think there are people who um
want to incorporate these concerns into
uh a capitalist system uh and are
otherwise quite politically moderate now
what I will say is that uh what reads
point and I cite him extensively in my
book because I find his work to be very
insightful um helps to explain is why so
many big corporations could get on board
with a program why is it that they all
put D'Angelo and Candi on the reading
lists why is it that Coca-Cola company
uh mandated its um employees to take a
training in which one of the slides was
how to be less white which turned out to
be just straight up racist things not
racist against white people but race
against non-white people like you know
uh don't care so much about punctuality
and worship of a written word and all of
those supposedly white virtues which uh
clearly are um uh you know character
traits of all kinds of human beings
irrespective of a group into which we
born why were they able to embrace these
ideas so quickly well because as direct
as as adol Reed points out the idea of
equity is compatible with the idea of
deep economic in equality um you know
Equity focuses our attention on economic
disparities between ethnic or racial
groups that's why Reed calls it race
disparar inis but this suggests that we
could have a just Society if only uh in
the United States where about 13% of the
population is black about 13% of
billionaires were black um and you could
come up with the equivalent figures for
the United Kingdom um in fact I I I I
think we may get to something like
racial equity in the United States but
by a rather bizarre route which is to
say and I know this is a topic that that
interest you in some ways um and you've
written about this interestingly in your
book um uh you know you have very very
successful black immigrants to the
United States um you know many of them
from countries like Kenya and Nigeria
and so on and then you have uh uh you
know a black population that has done
quite well in the last decades but has
really risen into the middle class many
cases but that does continue to suffer
um from disproportionate poverty and
disadvantage uh who are descendants of
American slavery and one of the ways in
which you might quite plausibly get to
equity in the United States is that the
you know kids in deeply deprived in
Dysfunctional schools in on the south
side of Chicago in the bad neighborhoods
of Baltimore um in the you know uh
certain parts of of of of of the Bronx
or of Brooklyn continue to be really
disadvantaged but you also have
sufficient high-skilled immigration um
from uh booming uh uh subsaharan African
countries um that on average a black
person is going to earn as well as a
white person or have as much uh wealth
as a white person in 50 or 100 years but
if this is a strange amalgam of people
who've immigrated and who outperform uh
white Americans um and you know people
who continue to suffer these real
disadvantages from the legacy of slavery
you know it's unclear how much we've
actually succeeded in overcoming the
injustices of American History so here
too This Racist petarian framework fails
in ways that uh somebody like Reed would
point out and I would agree with them
yeah fantastic um and speaking of
America to what extent do you think the
identity synthesis is a particularly
American phenomenon and what lessons um
do you think um your book would provide
to um people in the UK for example in
Europe or the rest of the
world well I again I think your your
book is is really brilliant pointing out
that um you know when people in Britain
are talk about race in particular they
speak in an American accent um uh and
and and so so so I think those ideas are
very influential in this idea um but but
they're also very influential in other
areas um influential when it comes to
gender which obviously has been a a very
significant debate in in in in the
United Kingdom um and and they structure
increasingly uh ideas about how we
should educate children in the United
Kingdom as well um I was struck this is
not I don't want to call King Charles
woke I think that may be an over
statement um but I was struck that he
recently said that we should think of
United of United Kingdom as a community
of
communities um which I think is a very
significant era um now of course a
country like United Kingdom will have
many communities within it and in fact
one of things I love about London or
other parts of the UK is its great
diversity and it's the fact that many of
the people who have Origins all over the
world continue to speak the language of
their um ancestors continue to be proud
of many of uh the the elements of
cultural heritage of of the ancestors
perhaps are more likely to be friends
with um or to marry members of of those
uh uh uh uh groups all of that is fine
all of that is part of what makes
Britain great but we also need to have a
self- understanding as people who are
not defined by those groups we also need
people who Strike Up friendships and
business Partnerships and perhaps
romantic relationships with members of
different groups um we must not
stereotype people into being defined by
the groups into which uh they were born
in part because many will have very
uncertain belonging in those because
they might have one parent from one
group or another parent from another
group or because there might be some
mighty Muslims who in a simplistic
scheme will be seen just as Muslims but
who actually um experience significant
discrimination within the Muslim
Community Based on their religious Faith
the idea of a community of communities
is very dangerous in that respect and I
was struck by the fact that somebody
like King Charles could could could
could could embrace it that too is part
of um the broader set of concerns
uh that I outline so um I think Britain
is half a step behind the United States
here I think there's more of an
opportunity to sidestep some of the
worst ideas of this um I am heartened
that Britain also has a left that has uh
that is inflected by some of these ideas
but that at least in its institutional
representation in the labor party has
also recognized that um it needs to draw
a line to the most extreme manifestation
of these ideas um but that doesn't mean
that this intellectual battle is not
going to come to the United Kingdom I
think it is going to structure
intellectual life in United States in
Britain in much of the European
continent in Australia and possibly in
parts of Asia in the kinds of ways in
which the fight over Marxism did for
many decades in the second half of the
20th century and so it's time to
understand where these ideas come from
understand how we became so
influential to to to learn how to
critique the main application of these
ideas as I do in my book on areas like
whether we can understand each other we
standard different intersections of
identities which I believe we can on
areas like where we should put forms of
mutual cultural influence between groups
under a general poll of Suspicion uh
invoking the label of cultural
appropriation which I think is a mistake
reflecting on why we need a genuine
culture of free speech why as we briefly
touched on we should be skeptical of
equity as a value that can supersede the
important value of uh equality and so I
hope to provide people with the
vocabulary and the framework for pushing
back against those ideas in my book
fantastic thank you very much jasha um
now for the audience Q&A I've got a
question from Raina the PO paa in um sa
Paulo um and this question is what if
what if there is a natural
insurmountable limit to our acceptance
of diversity
what if any minor difference is enough
to segregate other people um I think I
think the sort of the the line that the
question is is trying to um go for is
say that we become um and this is
something I've thought about a lot say
that we become um say a postracial
society as as think is like Thomas
ChatOn Williams often argues wouldn't
there be something else to replace um
race as a category to divide people is
there sort of natural human instinct
towards
division yeah it's a great question and
and and and I agree that psychologically
there there's something like that so I
um follow people like Jonathan height in
arguing that um human beings are by
Nature group is uh and there's some
really strong social psychology to
suggest this uh one of his studies was
carried out in United Kingdom in the
1960s um uh you know HRI tyel uh was
trying to figure out reflecting on the
Holocaust in World War II how it is that
members of different groups can come to
um be uh you know wonderfully altruistic
and courageous in helping members of
their own group but also often cruel
violence sometimes horrific in the
treatment of members of the out group
and he said look I'm going to create
groups that are so trivial that are so
devoid of meaning that they're not going
to have those Tendencies and then I can
Ladle on additional features and that'll
help us to understand what makes groups
tick this way and he got a bunch of kids
in Bristol uh into the lab and he showed
them a sheet of paper with 150 dots on
them and he said how many dots are on
this sheet of paper and they made a
guess and then he divided them into a
group of overestimators and
underestimators and had them play some
basic distribution games and to his
surprise it turned out that the
overestimators started to discriminate
against the under estimators and the
underestimators start to discriminate
against the overestimators so and this
is later uh uh recreated in in lots of
different ways I recreate it sometimes
in my classroom by asking my kids who
are super diverse who think themselves
as the most tolerant people in the world
whether not a hot dog is a sandwich and
at the end of a little bit of discussion
and debate the kids who think that a hot
dog is a sandwich start to discriminate
against the kids who think but a hot do
is not a sandwich so yes the ingroup
outgroup mechanism is absolutely
fundamental to humans that will always
rear its
head in part for that reason diverse
societies will always have different
communities within them always have
different tries of wom and that's fine I
have no problem with the fact that
people will have us subnational forms of
identity but that makes it over more
important for our institutions for our
social norms for our values to push
against that if you as so many schools
in America now do have as your goal of
your education to make children think of
themselves as racial beings to own the
racial
identity you may be trying especially
when it comes to white kids to create
candy style anti-racists people who will
denounce the white privilege but you're
much more likely to create racist and
white supremacists you're much more
likely to create people who are going to
say if this is the most important
identity I have when I should push
against others so the thing that can
help diverse societies succeed is a the
fact that how we conceive of ourselves
is malleable even if a tendency to uh
favor an ingroup over the out group is
not and be we can have multiple
identities that's why we need to
encourage a healthy form of patriotism
that's why we need to put people in
sports teams where they can um come to
see that they have things in common
cooperate across the lines that might
divide in the society not into racially
segregated Affinity groups where you're
doubling down on the dividing lines that
already structure our
Society great thank you Yasha um I've
also got a question from Libby and Libby
asks do you think that the excessive
individualism promoted by liberalism
provoked an inevitable backlash in the
urge to construct groups based on a
shared sense of identity and
victimhood these are great questions um
so it depends a little bit on how you
Define liberalism in this context I
think that people sometimes
misunderstand what the the basic
principles of liberalism consistent um
uh liberalism is not telling you to go
and cut your ties of all of your family
members at 18 and move to another
country and have a radical life of
self-exploration that is one of your
options that you have in a free Society
um but the basic moral and political
principles of liberalism are not telling
you that this is a better more
meaningful Superior way to live in fact
liberalism stems from the recognition
of the importance of uh the ties that
people have to their communities and the
Deep uh importance that they ascribe to
things like religion um the origin of
liberalism was an attempt to keep the
peace after decades and centuries of
religious war in which uh you know
having control of a state was a
necessary precondition for being able to
practice your religion and peace and so
some of a core liberal values principles
are what allows people to have ties to
their communities freedom of worship
freedom of assembly freedom of freedom
of movement all of those things are
precisely what you need in order to be
able to sustain communities so I think
liberalism rightly understood rejects a
perfectionist liberalism where everybody
like to me and I should be you know a
writer um uh thinking about the world
and U I know that's true of you but it's
somewhat true of me you know living a
you know
somewhat deracinated existence in in
different countries and traveling a lot
and so on that's one of the options you
have but there's nothing wrong for
liberalism for a liberal of somebody who
continues to live in the town in the
village continues to have strong
religious beliefs continues to um honor
the ties of of of of of of family and
kinship into which we born and nothing
in my book suggests that Vis are a
problem as well but if Society starts to
Define you purely by virtue of where you
were born if we start getting into a
communitarianism which says that you
don't have rights and duties as a
citizen but rather merely as a member of
a particular Community within that
National communities if we start to um
Embrace social norms that don't try to
get us to recognize what we have in
common at the same time as having
different identities but rather to
double down on the things that already
divide us then we're setting ourselves
up for a lot of political trouble great
um I've also got a question from inz and
the question is why do you think liberal
white people have been so ready to
identify themselves as group oppressors
and in your book actually um just to add
slightly to hz's question you you cite
the fact that um white liberal or
Progressive people are even more likely
to espouse the identity synthesis than
black American American people um which
I found interesting why why do you think
that is H that's a great question
um uh you know I think part of that
is a form
of elite
posturing
within that ethnic group which to say
that it is a way of
demonstrating your Superior light andl M
relative to the rest of um what
otherwise might be your own in group and
one of the things that I find
fascinating is you know i' I've been
warning about people like Donald Trump
for 10 years and I continue to be very
worried about him um but it strikes me
that if most Americans say generally
don't like Trump which is
true uh and yet so many Americans are
unwilling to cross the aisle and to vote
for the Democratic party at some point
perhaps it's time to look in the mirror
at some point it's time for me and my
friends and colleagues who are all on
the side of Joe Biden um to ask what is
it about us that makes people so angry
at us um and you know part of that is to
think
about uh the kind of social role we play
and the kind of snobism we have towards
others in United States was this idea
about the beer test because in 2004 more
Mal said they'd like to have a be with
George W bush than with John Carrey and
so since people had trouble
understanding how carry could have lost
therefore that must be it but that makes
no sense to me um most people know
they're never going to have a beer of a
president but what does make sense to me
is the inverse beer test if a president
showed up in your home today and you
didn't have time to redecorate or to
clean up and you talk to a president
like you talk to your friends what they
like you would they not like you and to
some extent in
Britain um
but but even more strongly in United
States It just strikes me that the
answer very clearly would be no for most
of the people I know and for most
politicians in the Democratic party um
that you know they have more empathy and
understanding for people with vastly
different views for you know rural
villages in India or for supporters of
Hamas may I say than they do for uh you
know working
class white Republican leaning
evangelicals in the Midwest of the
American South um and uh so I think this
sort of attempted
differenciation towards the own sort of
towards your own compatriots who you see
as your real um adversaries who you see
as the people who really and truly are
morally Beyond salvation in a way but
it's not true if anybody else in the
world um uh play some part in
that fantastic um I've got a very good
question I think a great question from
FEI and Fey asks how can we balance the
need for free speech with concerns about
hate speech and disinformation
particularly in the age of social
media so I must admit that I uh have
become mildly alergic to the idea of
misinformation um it's one when to talk
about disinformation which has a
technical
uh definition as you know State actors
trying deliberately through you know bot
armies and so on to affect public
discourse and I I I think was free
speech for individuals but not for Bots
um so so I think there you can do
something
misinformation um is this very very
Broad and vague term which covers um you
know things that
supposedly
um are wrong or misleading um but that
has been applied in it brief career to
things that turned out to be either
seriously worthy of consideration or
true one of the first areas in which
misinformation uh was was used to stifle
a debate was questions about the origin
of a CO virus um the so-call lab League
theory was labeled as misinformation um
and not only the New York Times And The
Washington Post and saw not report on it
for a very long time but uh uh you know
C scientists were kicked off Facebook
and YouTube for talking about it I'm
still not sure if it's true but it is
now taken seriously as a possible or
perhaps even the most likely explanation
for the origin of coid by uh you know
very serious institutions including most
intelligence agencies in the United
States so I'm a little bit concerned
about that you know in the last
weeks uh the BBC and the New York Times
and CNN all spread uh the claim that
over 500 people had been killed by an
Israeli air strike at a hospital in Gaza
um uh you know with huge headlines with
push notifications and so on it turned
out not only of it this was based on one
Claim by a uh doctor working for Hamas
but even on apparently a
mistranslation of what that doctor said
he had talked about casualties which can
include injured as well as non-injured
people and of course it turned out that
according to um independent
investigations in uh uh uh newspapers as
well as V assessment of various security
security agencies um very likely this
was a misfired rocket from Palestinian
Islamic Jihad in the Gaza Strip rather
than from Israel so who was spreading
the misinformation there um so so I I I
find that term a little bit concerning
but more broadly to the question of free
speech I think it is very important that
we fight not just for the laws of free
speech which are at threet in the United
Kingdom where um the criminal law has
become very Trigger Happy in find in and
sometimes jailing people for uh
offensive use um but more broadly a
culture of free speech and here we do
have to balance the freedom of
Association a core liberal value against
the attempt to push back against uh the
huge power that private companies now
have in regulating our lives and I think
that there's a few steps here the first
is to make it impossible for companies
to fire people for private political
views the second is to make it
impossible for companies to se to Ser a
business relationship with customers for
political reasons in particular
companies like Banks uh trained
companies airline companies um basic
internet service providers that are
required um to uh pursue basic functions
of life you should not be able to denite
boarding on a plane and you should not
be able to have your bank account
cancelled because of your political
views no matter how offensive they might
be but just not the sort of um business
that those companies should be in making
those judgments and finally I think we
need to push back against some of the
Hallmarks of quote unquote cancel
culture which go beyond critical culture
you should be very skeptical about uh
Collective letters uh trying to sort of
call for somebody's head you should be
very skeptical of secondary boycotts
that says unless you stop associating
with this person I'm going to stop
associating with you uh these are
elements of u a Culture of Fear that's
trying to impose uh invisible lines as
to where we can go which people are free
to engage in I'm not talking in this
respect about government regulation
against that because that itself would
interfere with our freedom of
Association but there are forms of
behavior that those of us who care about
preserving a genuine culture of free
speech should be very reluctant to
engage it thank you very much Yasha and
thank you to all of you for listening to
this
conversation thank you this is
great and thank you so much Yasha and
Tom for a really brilliant fascinating
thought-provoking conversation once
again here is yaser's book the identity
trap I do highly recommend it so now
from all of us at intelligence squ thank
you for watching and see you again soon
good
night
I